so my old PhD supervisor Jordan Pollock
told me that good old fashioned AI
programmers in particular list
programmers you should have an adage
that was if it's worth doing at all it's
worth doing recursively so if you had a
good idea about how to do a problem
faster then it would be a good better
idea to do it recursively and basically
this talk is about how to do
evolutionary processes in a recursive
fashion and where the biology can do
that and how to make sense of it so
we've seen a lot of discussion about the
relationship between evolution and
learning that we can view evolution as
an adaptive process that improves a
solution with experience and we've also
heard a lot of talk about the evolution
of evolvability which we might call
learning to learn or an adaptive process
that improves its ability to improve a
solution with experience now an
algorithm that learns how to learn is a
type of learning algorithm which is just
to say that the evolution of a
vulnerability is still evolution so it's
a little bit it's easy to get those two
ideas confused I think but they are
different ideas the kind of question
that you'd ask if you're thinking about
it in the first way is well that
different mechanisms or model spaces are
different learning algorithms I wonder
which one evolution is using right but
if you think about it in the second way
if the quest the relevant question is
what sort of model space allows movement
in the space of evolutionary processes
so what's the space of evolutionary
process is well biological evolution is
sometimes characterized as a Dominion
machine incorporating the fundamental
components of heritable variation in
reproductive success so we have a
population of genotypes with variation
they produce a distribution of
phenotypes some of those phenotypes get
through the sieve of selection and the
ones that do get reproduced fine but we
know that none of those mechanisms are
fixed in natural processes the
distribution of phenotypic variation
changes over evolutionary time as a
result of the evolution of developmental
interactions the evolution of the
genotype phenotype map and the selective
pressures on individuals change as a
result of the evolution of ecological
interact
between species and even the identity of
the evolutionary unit changes over
leveraged new time as a result of the
illusion of new reproductive strategies
or new mechanisms of inheritance or
genetic variation processes these two
might you might be okay with sort of
evolution of GP map evolution of niche
construction and this one might be a
little bit more unfamiliar so that I'm
talking about things like traits that
modify weather two genes are Co
disbursed or whether two individuals are
Co disbursed whether a parasite is
transmitted horizontally or vertically
compartmentalization changes in genetic
linkage the evolution of fare meiosis
homologous recombination track possible
elements etc etc all of those things
have effects on the evolutionary unit
the definition of the evolutionary unit
so what can change in the divine
duranium machine well genetic
developmental structures can change the
distribution of phenotypic variation the
evolution of social or ecological
interactions changes the nature of
selection on their phenotypes and the
evolution of reproductive structures
changes the genetic variation or
heritability of genetic combinations so
let's understand all of that okay so
that means that the products of
evolution modify the processes of
evolution or put another way the
Dominion machine is self referential
that circular causation people are
talking about it in particular in the
fields of the interaction between
evolutionary processes and developmental
processes such as it's clear that some
organisms are more evolvable than others
but can that evolved really absolutely
be adapted it causes a headache when you
think about it that way it causes a
headache because you think about the
Dominion machine is a fixed process but
we need to think about it as a process
that changes in the interaction between
evolution and ecology a good example is
that organisms certainly modify the
niche in which they live but can they
modify it in a way which has systemic
effects on the niche in which they live
for example to increase ecological
homeostasis or self regulation or are
they just as likely to [ __ ] it up so the
kind of questions which are burning
issues in evo-devo and evil eco are
essentially caused by the circular
causation that's implies in evolutionary
processes I think more importantly
evolution without self referential
mechanisms can't explain changes in the
level of the
unit which are characteristic of bio
complexity writ large I'm talking about
the major transitions in evolution where
the Dominion machine was originally
instantiated in nothing more than
self-replicating molecules in their
primordial soup and latterly in self
Romanick molecules in compartments and
latterly in simple sales and eukaryote
cells with organelles from a bacterial
origin then from single-celled organisms
to multicellular organisms and from
multicellular solitary organisms to use
social insects in each of those
transitions entities that were capable
of independent replication before the
transition can replicate only as part of
a larger hole after the transition I'm
quoting may not Smith since at Mary
there and we don't know how the
selection at one level of organization
is suppressed and heritable variation at
another level of organization is created
so I want to know how does the evolution
development modify processes phenotypic
variation how does the evolution of
ecological relationships modify the
processes of selection or the shape of
selection and how it is the evolution of
reproductions mechanisms modify
inheritance and how do those three
components work together in the
evolutionary transitions and
individuality such that the doing your
machine is reinstated at a new level of
organization I should be able to do that
in 20 minutes right and so here's my
take on what the hard questions are here
this is my controversial slide make sure
you pissed everybody off got their
attention before we move on and so you
don't understand anything in biology if
you don't understand evolution hopefully
we'll all agree with that but I would
say you don't understand evolution at
all unless you understand the evolution
of vulnerability and moreover you don't
understand the evolution availability at
all unless you understand how the
Dominion machine reinstates itself at
multiple scales of biological
organization only then would we have an
explanation for her biological
complexity arose because we only had a
dominion machine operating on the level
of self-replicating molecules in the
primordial soup all we must have these
good self-replicating molecules in a
soup so here's a little map yeah replace
the word level
they are definitely related yeah but
it's not just a matter of looking at the
same micro revolutionary processes over
different time scales to see Makka
revolutionary process that's that's the
whole issue of whether macro evolution
is just more microevolution right so
here's a map of the different models
that I'm going to talk about and model
of the evolution of development that
modifies interactions between components
within a unit of selection that model
that modifies the distribution of
phenotypic variation a model of the
evolution of sociological each
interactions or interactions between
multiple comparable to tional units that
changes the selection pressures on each
other and the evolution of reproductive
inheritance mechanisms that changes the
heredity whether things are selected
together or not and all together that
it's supposed to help us understand the
evolutionary transitions in all
probability in individuality so you know
maybe that's a little over ambitious but
I want to give you a sketch of some of
the work that I've done in those
different areas I would have more detail
on the first one because it's the most
well developed and it's the easiest to
understand the second one is quite easy
to understand after you've seen the
first one the third one is a little bit
tricky and then at the end I'll try and
pull that together to say well actually
there's really something very simple
going on here simple but important so
how can learning theory help us here
well machine learning characterizes how
a computational process can improve over
time as a function of past experience
including its own past behavior
importantly how come machine learning
principles possibly be relevant to
natural evolution well a lot of machine
learning is about building malls that
represent data or past experience and in
a lot of cases it's simply a case of
incrementally improving the fit of that
model to the data an incremental
improvement is something the natural
selection can do so the issue then
becomes where the natural selection has
suitable heritable variation that can
represent an appropriate space of models
to do good learning so let's very take a
very very simple way of thinking about
different classes of models first of all
we could
do a learning process that didn't have a
model at all so we treat each hypothesis
as though it's atomic it doesn't have
any internal structure we can change our
confidence in one hypothesis or another
hypothesis bid can't generate any new
hypotheses a simple type of model is a
univariate model where we treat each
variable as though it's independent we
know it isn't really there's complex
structure dependencies between the
variables but this kind of model
couldn't represent them if you didn't
like that you could move up a little bit
just a little bit to a bivariate model
that's capable of representing
correlations it's the minimal form of
interaction structure that you could
want from a model and then beyond that
there's all sorts of multivariate models
you could be thinking about how's that
relevant to evolutionary processes well
the first is genotype selection where
you treat a genotype as though it's just
an atomic thing you can't decompose some
genotypes are better than others some
genotypes increase in frequency in the
population and go down in the population
we've seen all too people formalizing
that the second one is allelic selection
some alleles increase in frequency in
the population other alleles decrease in
frequency in populations there might be
at the stasis between that there might
be frequency dependence between them but
a selection on allele frequencies can't
model a pit all you get is the additive
effects a bivariate model I think is the
mill emoni interesting case and it has
sufficient roots in the higher-order
models so correlations are a
sufficiently interesting kind of model
space that's why the perceptron is the
sort of minimal interesting kind of
learning and layers and vitali feldman
have shown us earlier in the week the
natural selection can do correlation
learning or more formally correlational
statistical query learning okay up as a
lien earlier in the week you can do that
if in it only if there's heritable
variation that affects correlations so
if you have some way of representing
correlations then you could select on
them and then selecting would have a
representation of the correlations but
it's sort of clear that there are many
examples where evolution does have
heritable variation that can affect
correlations so a regulatory interaction
between one gene and another gene
affects the correlation of the
expression of those two genes
okay so the first model the evolutionary
development there's been a number of
different models with HOD Lipson and
Cashman on along and various others also
in the population genetic literature
where you represent a genotype phenotype
map of some kind we're the matrix of
correlations we can think of this as a
matrix of gene regulatory interactions
the entries in that matrix are going to
tell us whether gene number one regulate
or down regulates gene number six etc
we're also going to evolve regina fight
vector which is sort of the direct
effects of the genotype on the phenotype
and then the phenotype is going to be
the multiplication to but diverging a
little bit from a lot of models that
other people have done that's going to
be a recurrent process so those two
things give us the phenotype of time
step one then we put the phenotype
through the matrix again it gives us the
phenotype of time step 2 and so on to be
get an equilibrium that's the adult
phenotype so we have a developmental
process that unfolds over time okay and
notice that I'm not learning an
input-output classification here just so
like I'm just going to select for good
phenotypes I'm going to select for a
matrix and a vector that gives me a
phenotype which is fit not a matrix that
does our mapping between an input and an
output so I'm going to select for two
different phenotypes if I select for
just one phenotype it's sort of
redundant to evolve a genotype phenotype
map that just produces one phenotype I'm
you do that with a straight through one
to one genotype phenotype map it has to
be at least two things that you want
your genes identified map to represent
so let's have two thing it's a big
target switch in there technically just
means i'm going to select for a
particular pattern of gene expression
levels in two different environments and
so which pattern of expression levels
shall I choose well without loss of
generality I may as well have a
well-known phenotype in environment one
and a another well-known finger type
environment to perhaps slightly less
bornholm that's a picture of Donald Hebb
of hebbian learning pain and so the
expression levels of the 200 pixels 200
genes are selected to produce a picture
of Darwin in one environment and
producer picture of head in the other
environment and it's important to
realize that in any one time selections
only acting on the ability to produce
one of those phenotypes it's not tested
on its ability to produce the
distribution of two finger types but of
course be interested in whether it does
there is something subtle there that I
might come back to later a little bit
that I'm going to select for a good
phenotype which is going to imply
selection or with genotype phenotype map
that's capable of giving me a good p but
i'm not actually selecting for a
particular genotype phenotype mapping
i'm just selecting for a good phenotype
so what happens well over evolutionary
time I'm switching back and forth
between these two environments and some
of the regulatory interactions are
becoming more positive some of the
regulatory interactions becoming more
negative and some of them are going up
in one environment and down in the other
environment if I look at the pattern of
positives and negatives and neutrals
makes a pattern is that a good pattern
well if I were to train a particular
kind of neural network to form an
associative memory of those two patterns
using heads rule it would do exactly the
same thing right so basically all it
says is that if two elements of the
phenotype vector are both expressed high
or both expressed no lo you increase
selection is going to increase the
regulatory interaction between them but
if one is selected high and the other
selected low then the regulatory
interaction which decreases the
correlation between them or Dan
regulates them one another is going to
be selected for that's the same as heads
rule which is just neurons that fire
together wire together and the type of
network that it's equivalent to because
the equations on a road gang were the
same is a hopfield network which is just
a fully recurrent neural network all and
neurons connected to everything else so
it's sort of obvious that a gene network
can behave like a hopfield net work
because they have the same equation of
motion but what's not so obvious is that
the change in regulatory interactions
and a gene network over evolutionary
time are the same as the changes in
synaptic connections in a neural net
work as a result of the application of
heads roll so that's what this shows so
what does that mean well now now that
I've evolved a genotype phenotype map
that we're switching back from for
between these two environments now I
have a genotype phenotype map which is
capable of producing a phenotypic
distribution with two attractors one is
a picture of head and the other is
picture of Darwin there are few screw
ones it's pretty good so the evolved
regulatory infractions have a track is
that correspond to the two targets that
have been selected for in the past so a
single gene network can remember more
than one phenotype that means it's the
sort of minimal case of of non-trivial
memory right if you're just going to
remember one thing then that's no more
memory than saying if I put the chair in
the corner of the room the chair will
remember the position where I put it
right but if you wanted something to
remember two things you have to be able
to learn correlations and that's what
this change network is doing you can do
some cold think cool things with the
Jing network that behaves in this manner
so I can give it a genotype vector that
looks a little bit like oh sorry looked
like a part of head and the expression
percolates through the regulation
network to give me back a complete
picture of head or I can give it a
little bit of Darwin and over
developmental time that gives me a full
picture of Darwin so development can
reproduce the complete phenotype from a
partial genotype also I could give it an
input vector that looks like head or an
input vector that looks like Darwin and
I can change the input vector linearly
proportionately from one to the other so
that in the middle here I have things
that are exactly halfway between heaven
Darwin but the response of the network
the adult phenotypes produced go head go
wrong yes all right hip hip hip hip that
went down with no one ever dying so
there's a very sharp transition between
the two attractors that are developed in
the system we can also do generalization
with it so development can produce novel
phenotypes that are new combinations of
learned features so here instead of
evolving to two targets are evolving to
a set of eight which have some modular
variation in them inspired by customer
loans work on modular to varying
environments we can interpret this as a
picture of an RNA loop
and a stem or a wing and a whole tear if
you like but there's some combinations
of lutes and stems which have been
selected for in the past and now let's
look at the distribution of phenotypes
that are produced by the evolved network
it's capable of reproducing all eight of
those but it also produces some other
phenotypes that were not selected for in
the past such as four hole pairs or four
wings so those are now in a sense
mutational neighbors of one another
their generalizations of features which
have been selected for in the past but
they're not coming up that particular
combination of features was never
selected for in the past so the gene
network is evolved over time to one of
these and then you change a random to
another one you change random to another
one and then I randomized to test what's
evolved to test what the attractors of
the gene network are I randomize the
genotype vector and see what it's
attractors are okay so what do we
conclude from that gene networks evolve
like neural networks learn gene networks
can store and recall multiple phenotypic
patterns that have been selected for in
the past and they can also generalize
the novel phenotypes that are from the
same family so I'm using family in the
sense that cached on that along use it
the gene part is going changing on a
faster time scale than the matrix yeah
which is sort of the network structure
yeah yes that's true and and as a
crucial if I have somewhat some time
scales yes it is if the gene network
involved too quickly then it would just
fit to a network that produced one
phenotype and then when you changed
environment it would just have all back
to produce that one phenotype it's
important it's on a separate time scale
and you're right to mention the
different time scales of style so the
fact that the selective pressures on
gene regulatory infractions are
identical to correlation than any neural
networks means that instead of neurons
of fire together wire together we have
gene
that are selected together wire together
and that's just coming from the fact
that selection is incrementing improving
the fifth of the phenotype to the target
is just minimizing the error follows
from that okay so we can go a little bit
further with the same model we're now
interested in we've shown how to shape
the distribution of phenotypes produced
by genotype phenotype map but how does
that affect the vulnerability and what
about that issue of how good a
generalization does it do and well in
natural selection there's no intrinsic
reason to evolve a GP map that's
beneficial with respect to future
environments of course especially if
that interferes with the goodness of fit
to the current environment so there's a
trade-off between performance now in the
current environment performance later
and that's the hard part of the
evolution of evolvability the reason
that's the hard part is because that's
the performance on the training set is
easy is the performance on the test set
that's the hard part with machine
learning right evolving fit phenotypes
is easy evolving a genotype phenotype
matter that's capable of anticipating
phenotype savant in the future that's
the hard bit so overfitting is a failure
to generalize and it's the result of
paying too much attention to the
training set and likewise the failure to
anticipate future environments can
result from the intrinsically myopic
nature of natural selection but the
conditions that alleviate overfitting in
machine learning are directly relevant
to the conditions that enhance
evolvability in evolutionary processes
such as limiting model complexity so one
of the talks earlier this week we talked
about Harold the advantage of selecting
on the individual features was that you
have a sort of regularization right so
having a limited model forces you to
generalize instead of overfitting in the
previous example with the loops and the
stens I deliberately picked a function
that the model i was using couldn't over
fit to it because the loops and the
stems if you look closely either had one
loop or three loops which is odd parity
and that's why it could only learn that
set by generalizing to the general class
they can't represent odd parity so it
just gives me any combination of
modules back but more generally is not
going to be that easy right but things
like regularization that we use in
machine learning or penalizing
unnecessary model unnecessary model
complexity are also relevant and this is
a direct parallel with Jeff glooms work
on evolved modularity through adding a
cost of connections so let's do a
different example here's the class I
wanted to learn there is structure here
so pairs of bits are always the same
here's the for training samples of for
environments I'm going to evolve it too
so it's a random subset of four from
that set and I'm going to test whether
it's capable of producing all of that
class after being evolved on those ones
well it's capable of decreasing the
error to zero on the ones that it's been
evolved to but if i look at the ability
of the grn to produce the whole class it
gets better at first and then it gets
worse that's a classic overfitting curve
if then I add a selective pressure for
sparse networks the ability to cope with
unseen environments improves
dramatically that is it's producing
phenotypes that are from the full class
and there's only a small cost in the
ability to match the environments that
it was actually in it's important that
there is a cost though because that
means that if you had a choice about
whether to add that regularization cost
or not you wouldn't you would rather
over fit can we get from the idea of a
flexible phenotype distribution that's
nice in general to the idea of
evolvability so Luis Chronos has been
working on this it's sort of clear that
a memory of past the past can obviously
be helpful if the future is the same as
the past but if the future is the fact
that we have generalization as well
means that it could be useful even if
the future is not the same as the past
but it's similar in structural ways and
so here's some examples of what happens
to fitness immediately after a changed
environment in the to environment case
this is the speed of adaptation back to
high fitness with the old with the
immature genotype-phenotype map and this
is where the maturing applied for my map
later and evolution
in other cases there's something a
little bit more interesting happens
which is it's actually slower to respond
with the maturity inflection effect map
but first this is essentially an
effective canalization that even though
the environment has changed it's still
producing the phenotypes for the old
environment but when it passes a certain
threshold it says oh you wanted me to do
the other phenotype then it switches
rapidly to produce the other phenotype
it's that's evolving faster bits not
evolving better it doesn't get too many
where this this guy didn't get to in the
first place here's another example
arisen that's sorry masters no it
doesn't it doesn't find better solutions
it just gets the same solution faster
yeah faster is better to a biologist
numbers and so this is a different
problem where instead of evolving in a
more in a varying environment I'm going
to evolve it in a single multimodal
environment lots of times from different
random initial conditions and the
environment is a locally weighted match
to a target image or a thin verse which
is equivalent to a local locally
weighted max to set organizing models
that will appreciate and revolving
multiple times from random additional
vectors at first it gets local domains
in agreement but there are often borders
or boundaries between other local
domains that are in disagreement by the
way the target image is in case you
don't recognize it it's supposed to be a
double helix we're working on the
resolution and so the first time you try
to evolve in that Fitness landscape you
find something locally optimal the
second time you've already find
something locally optimal and so on in
fact even like thirty three generations
later each one but over time it gets
better at finding larger localized
domains which are in agreement and so
eventually it's able to produce either
the target image or its complement
reliably yeah I just check the model
this is
evolution paper model runs in the making
no it goes beyond that the matrix is
that be just randomly changing my heavy
no the matrix is being involved I ran a
variation and selection but it's much
slower rate than the vector yes so
there's a decision well the heavy
learning case has directed change in the
in the interaction coefficients and here
we're doing random variation and
selection but if you only need to change
one interaction term at a time so since
that's each interaction term is a
one-dimensional paying you fifty percent
of your mutations improve it is that
it'll make it worse so it's not much
slower than doing it in a directed
fashion but the difference here is that
the matrix is evolved random in the
vector of the matrixes of all yeah so if
we look at how the evolved network is
able to evolve good phenotypes in this
multimodal landscape we find that not
only is it much faster than the immature
network that basically is a one-to-one
mapping but it also finds something that
are bitter right it finds the global
optimum of the fitness landscape and not
just a local optimum and even if we run
it I said you're going to have to run it
longer than that Louis because they're
going to think it might get there
eventually but it is really stuck on
local Optima so that's sort of
interesting because it means that the
evolved biases of the Jews life in a
site map of hidden the fine-scale
details of the fitness gradients that
was distracting the 121 genes lifetime
map and causing it to get stuck and it's
smoothing out the fitness landscape
instead using a generalized past
experience to go straight for the goal
and ignore those little distractions so
the idea of bivariate associative models
being as a way of understanding genic
like things like map helps us understand
things like robust models of the
Selective environment faster allocation
and better adaptation none of this
involved in multi-level selection right
or even population I've actually hill
climbing the
mutation and selection process is just a
1 + 1 EA if you might like to call it
that let's go on to the second one this
is the evolution of social ecological
relationships or interspecies
interactions in an ecosystem so in a
gene networks they alter the
distribution of phenotypic variation or
the interactions within a single unit of
selection but in the ecological networks
there are interactions between multiple
units of selection so something
different going on there and instead of
the gene network we have an any species
lockable terror model of non trophic
ecological interactions and we're going
to evolve the interaction coefficient
saw the community matrix that control
the ecological fanatics but we're going
to evolve them by individual natural
selection there's no population of
ecosystems here or even a fitness
function evaluating the quality of the
attractor of an ecosystem each species
is just changing his interactions with
other species to maximize its own growth
rate but we're going to put this
ecosystem under varying environmental
conditions under one environmental
conditioning the carrying capacities of
some species of our higher that those
species are intrinsically better suited
to one environment and other species are
less suited and in the other environment
the species that are better suited are
different the subset of species that are
well suited to different than the subset
of species that are not also good at
different so we can still represent that
it's to image but these images are a
picture of the carrying capacities of
the set of species in two different
environments they're not targets that
I'm trying to evolve to well what
happens some ecological species
interactions go up some go down some
stasia 0 and the consequence of that is
the ecological attractors of the
lockable Terra model are able to
reproduce those two attractors from any
initial conditions we can test that
they're stable so if I give it an
ecological condition and a set of
species NCS that's a bit similar to one
of the attractors has been carrying
capacity patterns it's been evolving in
the past it goes to that dick illogical
attractor and if I give it one that's a
bit similar
but no you see that one is when it goes
to that one I can also give it just some
species that are part of this pattern
and it gives me the whole climax
community if you like or some other
species which are relevant which are
matched the first patent it gives me to
develop at the others climax community
and just for the fun of it why don't we
look at the response of the ecosystem to
environmental forcing and how that
changes over time so early in time the
response of the ecosystem to
environmental forcing between hot and
cold is just a linear response but after
the species interactions have been
evolving for a while hot in a while a
cold and while hot and wild cold the
consequence of that is that now the
ecological response has a hysteresis
loop in it which Krul's is a
catastrophic regime shift between one of
the other as I change the environmental
forcing this way it stays in the hot
pack up on top button then it goes to
the cold patent and I have to force it
all the way back again this way before
it would flip back so if your two types
of coexistence there are many species
coexisting here in each attractor video
yeah but the set of species in one
attracted doesn't coexist with the set
of species in the other attractor and so
these ideas the same idea is help us
understand the evolution of the
ecological interactions that control the
distribution of ecological equilibria
and how that's shaped by past
environmental conditions and the
evolution of memory and learning
behaviors influencing ecological
robustness and stability of brazilians
regime shifts that means that there's an
organized interaction network structure
and holistic behaviors without any
multi-level selection going on in the
ecosystem okay so those two models seem
like they do basically the same thing
right they seem like they're just
basically both hopfield net works in
disguise what's the difference between
the two well in the gene networks the
interactions are within a single unit of
selection and selection is acting on the
attractor of the whole system whereas in
the ecological networks selection is
acting on individual speed
to maximize their individual growth so
there's no selection for a particular
pattern regardless of how many teeth it
has the selection merely to dwell on the
pattern that the ecosystem is already
forced to write so the ecosystem is
forced to a particular pattern by the
environmental conditions and the effect
of the evolution of the interactions
between the species is just to canalize
that pattern so the attractor of the
ecological network isn't a good
attractor it's just the ecosystem is
remembering it because it's not
remembering it because it's good it's
just a memory of where it's been right
well that's the difference between
supervised and unsupervised learning
isn't it so in supervised learning that
reinforces correlations that are good
when you do selection on the whole
system we're selecting for a specific
target and the correlations that match
their target better other correlations
been evolved but in unsupervised
learning that just reinforces
correlations that are frequent not
correlations but good the correlations
that are already there in the data
independent of what you want to do with
them so selection on the parts on the
individual species is equivalent to
selection has the effect of reinforcing
what the system was already doing
regardless of whether that was good or
bad there's nothing about this system
that would enable the yuca system to
produce the combination of species which
was good right it's just producing the
combination of species so it's been
forced to in the park this is a good me
your secret doesn't really discards it
doesn't for thee because you're my cozy
assistant doesn't have any fitness
that's a good point just bring me a good
under there doesn't collapse as you
changing right yeah well it's the thing
that's being selected for is that each
species maximizes its own growth rate
that has the side effect of producing a
network of species which have a
particular structure of interactions
with one another that is robust but I
wasn't selecting for it's a side effect
of selecting for maximum quote that
isn't that supervised learning i think
that's reinforcement
do not be supervised learning video
given the right answer in order to eat a
building for reinforcing or giving 11
bit of feedback 11 the scale of feedback
that's reinforcement yeah okay yeah what
might be right Thanks yeah so system
level selection we're not surprised that
gives a system level annotation when I
volva gene network to give us good
phenotypes it does but when I select on
the parts that makes the parts adaptive
the species are quite happy but it gives
us system level robustness what is the
relationship between the system level
robustness coming from selection on the
parts and the system level adaptation
that we would normally expect to see
from selection on the whole well that's
the same as what's the relationship
between unsupervised and supervised
learning well we know that uncivilized
layman can guide supervised learning
unsupervised learning reduces the
dimensionality of the data builds a
lower dimensional model of the data can
be used to reduce the dimensionality of
a supervised learning task such that
unsupervised learning Prime's good
performance at supervised learning tasks
and the combination of unsupervised
supervised learning is useful in
learning high dimensional or deep models
if the amount of labeled data is limited
but put another way robust low
dimensional models of data are useful
for finding good models of the next
level up so that brings us to deep
learning or a deep belief net which work
like this so this is a type of neural
network where you add layers to the
network incrementally so we learn one
layer of associations with a restricted
Boltzmann machine there is unsupervised
learning that's just correlation and
then we freeze it and then we put
another layer on network and we learn
correlations among those plus received a
lot of attention recently in machine
learning community works pretty well and
each layer is only learning a pairwise
model which makes each they are quite
tractable to learn but there's an
interesting question here how can the
first layer of the network be useful for
the next layer of the network they
haven't started yet this is the first
layer of the network have foresight of
what you're going to do
it's larry the network well no because
all the first layer in the network is
doing is reducing the dimensionality of
the data which is a good heuristic
regardless of what you want to do in the
next level and which is another way of
saying regularization improves
generalization so the analogy I want to
make is that the major transitions and
evolution can be thought of as an hour
of deep evolution with an a lot of deep
learning so individual section acting
all the relationships between multiple
units of selection modifies the
ecological attractors reinforces
correlations that are frequent then a
change in the reproductive unit freezes
those solutions and then selection can
now respond to competition between those
phenotypes selection for good
combinations of individuals and not just
frequent combinations of in equilibriums
so instead of just going to the nearest
equilibrium and freezing it we are able
to do competition between equilibria or
equilibrium selection but how do we do
that freezing that's where we need the
third mole so now we're going to talk
about traits that affect the
reproductive unit or changes in the
evolutionary unit we've seen
interactions with any of you seen
interactions between you it's how about
the level of evolution unit changes over
evolutionary time or change the
definition of self and other well how
did you do that well here's one method
of inheritance this is a migrant poor
aggregation and dispersal model of
inheritance so you have a lot of
particles in different groups but when
the groups only reproduce by the
particles entering a migrant fall and
then reforming or aggregating into
different groups although these groups
might be different that some groups
might be better than others because of
differences the differences between
groups are not heritable into the next
population of groups its return to
linkage equilibrium a different model of
inheritance is a vertical model of
inheritance where groups fission and
this is interesting because it means
that the some group might be better than
others because of the combinations of
particles that they have and when they
fission the different
between groups are heritable so the
first model is sometimes called a type
one group selection a second one is
coming type 2 group selection or MS 1 +
ms 2 they're basically the difference
between horizontal transmission and
vertical transmission of the heritable
particles we could be talking about
genes in an organism or multiple
organisms with multiple self-replicating
molecules within a compartment or
multiple organisms within a host and
whether they're transferred versity or
belong to me so group selection is
explicit in the second case where you
have a group visioning process the
groups have the differences between
groups are heritable and that means you
have a you know a stronger ability to
respond to selection at the graduate
level if you have heritability of the
group variance but what if organisms had
traits that change the mode of
reproduction from horizontal to vertical
reproduction what sort of traits could
do that well the evolution of membranes
that change a population from being
freely mixed as facial to
compartmentalize or the evolution of
recombination rate or more interestingly
the evolution of the genetic map there
changes things from recombining freely
to being genetically linked or the
evolution of symbiotic relationships
that change from being coevolution to
being endosymbiosis where a parasite is
transmitted politically so here we can
start off with a microphone model but
allow particles to evolve things that
make them stick together selectively so
I'm just going to say this is work by my
zune adam jackson and that an
evolutionary change forms a new
partnership at random it takes two
little things that used to replicate in
the pen Linda's book you together around
a group means the two individuals are
thereafter treated as a single unit it's
like the handcuffs that Manfred was
talking about yesterday I assume that
the ecological dynamics are faster than
the evolutionary dynamics so you make
handcuffs and brake handcuffs slowly but
the ecological canals are fast sending
separation of time scales as before and
the ecological population dynamics has
multiple equilibria that are generated
from a modular weighted coordination
game and I know that if you found the
right group structure that corresponded
to that one
coordination game it would make solving
those constraints easy but is that the
structure that individual selection
finds no it's not what happens if you
let them make Hank Russell is one
another is that it goes to a local
ecological equilibrium and then
everybody that's there just makes
handcuffs with everybody so that's not
what I wanted that doesn't do anything
interesting it does change the unit of
selection from individuals to ground
coalition's in-game spirit from directly
from individual to crank coalition's but
that doesn't change the ability of the
system to evolve in any interesting way
so what if I keep the ecological system
the larger population dynamics out of
equilibrium which handcuffs all men all
I'm going to use the handcuffs
metaphorical yes da well they still make
lots of handcuffs but then the the
pattern of hand cupping that they do is
much more random but if I perturb the
ecological dynamics occasionally so that
it spends most of its time at ecological
equilibria whether the distribution of
ecological equilibria over time
something more interesting happens which
is that particular groups of species in
handcuffs with one another but not with
everybody those groups are the right
groups that correspond to the modular
coordination game that I knew was there
so one of the selective pressures on
form on forming those groups well at any
equilibrium there are many partnerships
that are bad if you try to form a
partnership with the species that's not
pregnant without delivering that would
be bad because they're selected again so
you don't want to have a partnership
with something that's already selected
against there are none that are good and
there are no single partnership to get
evolved that would enable you to get her
exact equilibrium because if there was
that single partner could have invaded
it would mean it wasn't an equilibrium
but there amongst the ones that are not
bad there are some that event ones that
are not good there are some that are bad
and something in neutral and that
distinction is important so the ones
that are neutral some of the ones that
are neutral in the nutrient one second
environment some of those will be
neutral in many ecological conditions
and some of them only knew
a few the selection is basically
retaining the most reliably neutral ones
the most reliably robust ones or
non-military partnerships its selection
for robustness not individual fitness
advantage that's causing those
partnerships to evolve the symbolic
partnerships an evolved a heavy n again
species recover together wire together
but does the encapsulation of subgroups
from the ecological detractors into new
evolution units do anything other than
find the structure that I put their
right it was motivated by selection for
responding to reverse but does it
produce new high-level units that are
good that increase the amount of
cooperation rather than just catalyzing
the cooperation will already have so
here's what happens when you don't have
the evolution of partnerships some of
those little compartments are evolving
towards attractors that have a high
number of corporators and some to a low
number of co-operators because
individual selection doesn't care about
whether you go to the good attractor all
of an attractive and if you don't allow
it with all partnerships with one
another they just stay there they can
never get out of those attractors that's
why the core detractors but if you wait
long enough those partnerships that are
robust or reliably non to the terious
evolved and those partnerships are
actually the right partnerships for
combinations of species to be able to
leap from one attractor to another so
that when they go from one pool to
another pool they take the right species
with them so that they can get out of
that equilibrium and all invade together
so no one of them could have alien
dividual II which is why it was in
equilibrium but together they can and
they find the right partners to do that
so that long period of apparent neutral
evolution is not doing nothing it's
evolving structural relationships
between components will have their
consequences the future evolution but
that couldn't have been the reason that
it did it right it couldn't have been
evolving those partnerships because in
the future they were going to be good
and he was evolving those partnerships
because at the time they increased
repugnance robustness so you can take
those principles and throw away all of
the evolutionary components and just
make an algorithm that works so this
paper accepted
year this month shows that in a simple
hierarchy new modular problem sort of
hierarchical rising whole takes
exponential time for other kinds of
evolutionary algorithms but solve in
polynomial time and it has no a priori
information about the structure of the
linkage which problem variable
independent of which are the point
variables so you don't have to know how
to make the hierarchy that's right you
don't have to be clever sorry you don't
have to be clever on how you do the
hybrid the algorithm has to figure out
what the higher if he is but I don't
edit and so where are we at how can we
make sense of these three models
together well all three models are if
you like about modifier alleles that
alter correlations in some way they are
the evolution of alleles that alter the
correlations among phenotypic traits or
the evolutionary alleles that alter the
correlations among selective pressures
or the evolution of correlations but
also genetic inheritance but if it was
just a single by firewheel none of these
models would be interesting because a
single modify really all can't hold much
information about the past a network of
modifier alleles can hold a lot of
information about the past and that's
why it get more interesting results now
in all three cases the reason that they
evolved for what the thing they hold for
its selection for a directive benefit
that regulatory interactions improve
individual fitness or species
interactions improved individual species
growth or synthetic partnerships that
are reliably long to the terrace but the
effect of those things in each case is
to cause the selection of an associative
model I wasn't selecting for associate
model but I got an associate model so
it's an associative model of previously
selected phenotypes reinforcing good
associations or an associate model of
past ecological states reinforcing
common associations or associate model
of parts theological states which
changes us the subset of
associations and aims of the set select
between the subset of associations that
are stable to find the associations that
are good wider selection for phenotypes
produced selection of an associative
model or a bit phenotypes well it's not
mysterious right the only way to reduce
the error between the actual output of a
model in the desired I protocol model is
to make model fit the data better and if
the model space is constrained to be the
order for example associative it'll have
to be a generalized representation of
the data not because generalization is
being rewarded explicitly but because
your model space is limited on natural
oil space is limited in ways that force
useful generalization a sort of
necessary side effect is useful
generalization well associate models are
the minimal departure from a univariate
model which can't represent any
structure at all and although biological
systems in some cases could represent
more than pairwise correlations there's
always going to be a stronger selective
signal for correlations that are better
pairwise than for higher order terms
just because the signal for higher order
terms is going to be much rarer there is
a cause an even stronger selection for
the univariate terms but when the
univariate terms are exhausted the pairs
are next and after you canalized appears
the meta pairs are next I guess I want
to end the argument as to why I or
contributor it's just because you just
because you're going to see them more
rarely right so there could be there
could be a signal that particular
combinations of genes for example
particular combinations on eels are
extremely fit right so they could be
very important for fitness but your
ability to solve all those combinations
is is very loose either not whether they
develop if you can't see them they're
not going to evolve so the things that
you can see you're going to be the
population that are going to be the if
you don't know which ones to look at so
they can be higher order one today which
is very hard to find because they're a
huge number of possible I ruins yes okay
so if you wanted a build if you wanted
to jump in at the top and let's say I
want to build five way a [ __ ] order
five model right so there might be order
five dependencies in my fitness
landscape that I could exploit if I
could see those it's going to be very
difficult for me to find them because
the number of possible models is if
these growing exponentially with the
order of the model with the number of
possible five-fold of combinations is
also very exposed for my ability to
sample the business matter your
abilities ample develop well if I have
that if I have a model that represents
the wrong order five correlations I
won't be able to see the order five
correlations that I could have sex it up
the questions like what fraction of the
potential order five combinations
actually are there yes what how does the
the fashion that are good fell off with
the yeah yeah you're right hey somebody
you're battling a nice entropy and
energy like arguments yeah i think the
it's a rather crucial thing for looking
g wasn't so all right different looking
finding correlations and the question
the crucial ones the question whether
they're clear hey yeah okay and so
I'm arguing that the ability to respond
to pairwise associations is much
stronger than the ability to respond to
higher order correlations because they
are more common yes and the model
spacing after searching it's more but
that's why hierarchical dissociative
models the learning neural networks
that's why they're powerful and that's
why they're good in machine learning
it's not a mysterious observation that
hierarchical pairwise models are good so
let's conclude then winning machine
learns not just by changing the product
of evolution it's not just the product
of evolution that have information about
the circuit history but by changing the
mechanisms of evolution and none of the
components of the Dominion machine of
fixed machine learning concepts can help
us understand how are the variation
distribution changes how the selective
pressures change how the reproductive
mechanisms change and how they work
together in the evolutionary transitions
I think the main imagine or understand
the evolutionary transitions is the
analogy between deep learning and deep
evolution that simple principles of
correlation learning can be used to
reduce the dimensionality the space
explorer encapsulate variables into
emerging high level variables and then
the process can recurse and a rescale
abordo ironing dominion machine has
different optimization capabilities to a
fixed machine different certainly better
for the same reason that deep learning
has better ability to learn high level
representations in principle this is the
heuristic that you're exploiting is get
everything you can from a simple model
before moving on to a higher order model
evolution I'm claiming then is an
adaptive process that improves its
ability to adapt with experience an
algorithm that learns how to learn is a
type of learning algorithm and that
means that the evolution of mobility is
still evolutional so it's easy to get
those two things confused right but the
question that you're asking to think
about it is well it's all just evolution
is you'll ask what different mechanisms
and model spaces are they correspond to
different learning algorithms so which
one is biology using but if you're
interested in how evolution improve
ability to interact with experience then
you want to ask what sort of model space
allows movement in the space of doing
machines and the models that I've shown
you was supposed to give examples of
traits they're available that can move
in that space and the conditions where
they do so I think that all that process
is exactly as mysterious as the fact
that generalization is possible in
machine learning now in general
generalization isn't possible and
machine learning because I could give
you a training set and then I could give
you a test set there's nothing to do
with it right but so long as we want to
make any weak assumptions about the
structure of the training set being
related to the structure of the test set
that makes generalization possible so
the ability of the Dominion machine to
rescale itself is exactly as mysterious
as the cake the fact that generalization
is possible in machine learning but it's
no more mysterious than that I don't
think of texture all those people that
have helped with that work thank
totally confused about the supervisor
can you just a business executive what's
doing the supervisor so in when I'm
evolving a team network and I'm evolving
it to produce an output that that is fit
it's like I'm doing supervisor right
give me the correlations that improve
the out front that's definitely not
super why's that ok surprise learning is
when you are actually making directed
changes based on a specific base of
knowledge of the actual answer rather
than knowledgeable with the writing of
the answer yeah pretty nice returning
you get a possible negative feedback
when the change was good or bad
supervised learning you're told ito yeah
ok whatever you need super yeah maybe
I'm sorry hopefully earn it here yep so
in your model you didn't you didn't have
a recombination it seems to have just
mutation in the gene network there's no
recombination in the species model each
species is talking there's no
recombination in the last model it's
effectively changing from something
which has free recombination to
something that doesn't okay let's say
you start with something that has free
recombination yeah but could cook like
XA should be one of the freezing
mechanisms so the trouble with that is
that it's this issue of
and if I if I put a chair in the corner
of the room the chair remembers the
position where I put it right it's a
it's a it's only memory in a degenerate
sense since only memory in the canoe
remember one thing at the time right
what we need is a memory that's
structural but that's about hidden
variables and not carry the surface
variables if it's about the surface if
its memory in the surface variables you
can only remember one thing if I ask you
to remember a second thing you have to
move the surface variables over to the
second thing but if you have hidden
variables which represent structural
relationships between those surface
variables they can represent a memory
that enables you to move the surface
variables freely i still have
variability in all of my alleles but
I've still learned something about
phenotypes that are good right so I'm
not seeing fixation I'm not seeing
convergence you know of or all alleles
and sing convergence of particular setup
of the fixation of just a set of values
yeah but you don't want to remove
variation from any of your alleles and
you still want the alleles to be
variable otherwise there's nothing left
to do at the next level of organization
well this is the rest of you reduce the
dimensionality there's the yes but only
in a sequential fixation sort of way
right so that's not a hierarchical
process that's a digital process of
sequential fixation right which is an
interesting thing to do but it doesn't
enable you to produce a recursive
process if you want a recursive process
where you start it off with variable
bits you want later to have variable
modules but it has to be more than one
solution to each module otherwise you
can't search combinations and modules
there's no point searching combinations
of things that each thing only has one
solution right there so you still want
variability within each of your
subsystems but you want that variability
to be constrained and not free other way
to have learnt anything so to be the
next job
uh-huh I didn't ask you that in your
talk okay so there is biological
evidence for what are called quantitive
relational traits relational
quantitative trait sorry for the
Michaela pavlica in Gunter of study
which show that there are traits that
modify the correlations between two
other traits and it's easy it's it's
there exists theoretical models that
show that the selective pressures on
those relational trades should follow
the principles of heads are all other
they didn't name it as hips rule so if
you were if you're able to measure those
relational traits and the frequency of
those relational traits in the
population then you should be able to
show that that correlated selection on
the traitors or produces that result
right however that wouldn't produce an
integrated system of sort of information
integration across the genome if that's
what you're looking for right if it's
just a single trait that controls the
correlation between two others and
although there could be many of those it
only really gets interesting when
there's non linear recurrence because
then the information can spread across
the network you know in an interesting
way otherwise you just to sort of have a
superposition of the pairwise things
pairwise things that would be that would
be more difficult but I don't see why in
principle you couldn't do exactly the
experiment that I've done in simulation
so you evolved for a particular gene
expression pattern you evolved for
another particular gene I should happen
and then you examine the distribution of
phenotypic expression pattern equilibria
that you get from the system